Now that I've given some
kind of motivation for
this notion of generalization, it might
be worth talking about what exactly
we are trying to generalize between
different learning opportunities.
So what are the functions that we're
actually making use of when we're doing
reinforcement learning?
>> What do you mean?
>> When we're learning we're actually
generally learning some mapping right.
So this is true in reinforcement
learning in general.
There's some mapping
from input to output.
>> I see what you mean.
So, well, the whole goal,
of course, is to learn a policy, which
is a mapping from states to action.
>> Great.
Okay, that seems like a really good
place to start.
So policy maps states to actions.
>> But that's usually hard.
So we usually learn some
kind of intermediate thing,
like a value function.
>> Well, let's just stick with
policy here for a second.
So in terms of the policy.
Generalization would mean that to
the extent that similar states
have similar actions.
Then we could learn what the right
action is for some states and then
guess what the right action is for other
states, using some kind of I don't know.
Function approximation,
some kind of supervised learning.
>> Right, so if you're in a state
where an anvil is about to hit you on
the head,
you should probably jump out of the way.
That's probably true for
every state where an anvil's
about to hit you in the head.
Even if you never seen the specific
details of that state before.
>> Yeah,
I mean it could matter whether or
not there also is a shark
tank right in front of you.
So when you jump out of
the way of the anvil,
you actually jump into the shark tank.
But yeah, I think that's exactly right.
That we want to be able to
say across lots and lots and
lots of related states, we could
be using the same kind of action.
But I think what you're pointing
out is that we don't know how to
learn the policy directly.
Anyway, when
we're talking about these kinds of
reinforcement learning algorithms.
So, we usually learn a kind
of a stand in for it.
>> And
my favorite one is the value function,
which is where you are now mapping
states to some number to r.
>> Right.
So we can map, for example, states and
actions to the estimated return.
That's what the q function does and
that's another function that we could be
trying to learn and this is another
function where generalization might be
an option, right.
So to the extent that similar state
action pairs have similar returns,
again, because if an anvil's
about to hit you on the head.
Probably that's a bad state,
you're in a bad situation across
all the different kinds of states where
handles about to hit you in the head.
>> There we go that you.
You should draw a picture of me
standing off to the side to your left.
I have the world's tallest neck.
>> Yeah.
So
say I'm in a state where enamels
about to hit me on the head,
there's lots of other details that
are sort of not that important
in predicting what the estimated
returns going to be.
So you even look kind of concerned.
>> That's supposed to be me?
>> Yeah you're tall enough.
>> Okay, fair enough.
>> So this is another place where we
could be doing function approximation,
is in the actual q function itself.
And there's a third one that I think
is actually really important and
interesting, and that is the model.
To the extent that you can actually do
a good job of predicting next states,
transitions for related states.
Then you could actually be
doing function approximation or
generalization in the model as well.
>> Right.
In fact, that's probably very,
very important often.
>> Yes.
Not only is it important but
it's actually often really natural place
to do it because when you're learning
a model right so
what is it about learning a model?
You're in some state,
you take some action, and
you observe what net stage you're in.
These are actually supervised
examples of transitions.
So unlike learning the policy or
learning the value function,
when you're trying to learn the model,
you're actually getting
standard supervised examples.
So that being said using function
approximation models it has been
done in the field but
it's not that well understood.
In particular, you need models that can
actually predict many many steps ahead
to be able to be used effectively for
planning and decision making.
Mostly what researchers have focused on
is function approximation in the value
function, the generalization
of the value function.
So that's what we're going to look
at in the rest of this lesson.
>> Okay cool, look forward to it.